what were the hardest and the easiest
aspects hardest part was covered hardest
part really did really rough really
really rough for everybody because well
because because we were shut down a
couple of times and we had testing every
other day so that part was a little bit
confusing yeah and rough on everybody
and we had 100 a crew of about a hundred
people casting through 100 people so
every now and again we'd get Chuck you
know we had problems right but you know
everybody was so strong and everyone was
so anxious to make this work and I think
it does I I'm very proud of it if we
intend to live past Sunrise we have to
steal their souls wait can we talk about
this no
are you just so excited to slip back
very excited I just slipped back into
character with Chris after 30 years why
did you keep us waiting so long
don't look at me
Ben has spoke I do love a franchise yeah
we did I've never had one hi Tony how
are you come on come on I know right
[Music]
now well done well done theme of
Sisterhood here in this film is so
lovely is that what brought you back
that's a scene with him I know nearly of
course he's standing 20 feet away but
he's it's still a scene I mean come on
this was a gift was it a dream come true
it is it is
I saw your monologue when I saw your
monologue I didn't I lost it I thought
it was great you were meant to be a part
of it
it was just a huge gift
that this is something
Goldie Hawn you guys get
them I love my Goldie Hawn I do love my
Diane and Diane Keaton has the single
best Instagram
in the world she really does it's
brilliant I'm a fan you can post that
she is Dan thank you so much
[Music]